we know that this country the defining
feature of it is pervasive racism
that's what the left tells us and we
need to root that out from the very very
beginning which is why now
in new jersey five-year-olds in
kindergarten
are receiving training in
diversity equity and inclusion they are
receiving so-called
anti-racism training the
democratic governor of new jersey phil
murphy signed this
bill into law forcing
teachers to instruct students as young
as five
in diversity and inclusion and equity
intolerance and belonging in connection
with
gender and sexual orientation race and
ethnicity
disabilities and religious tolerance
now forget you know whenever you hear
this term diversity inclusion and equity
or any permutation of that
what that means is leftist orthodoxy
that's what they're going to be trained
in from a young age
and i've seen some people protest this
and they've said
you know babies aren't racist is another
one or you know little children
aren't bigoted and we don't we don't
need to teach them this if you want to
have this kind of program of education
wait until later i think those
conservative critics are totally missing
the point
this makes perfect sense if you want to
get your country to be more left-wing
it's not going to be nearly as useful to
teach 18 year olds as it will be to
teach eight-year-olds as it will be to
teach five-year-olds
the younger kids are the more malleable
their minds are the less they know the
easier it is to shape
the way that they view themselves the
way they view the world the way they
view the country
and so absolutely if i were a left
winger i'd want to get into kindergarten
frankly i think
we should get into the kindergartens as
conservatives and teach students
not this radical gender theory or
whatever we should get into the
kindergartens and teach them
what they were once taught in
kindergarten namely george washington
was a good guy
our country is a good country a country
that you ought to have
loyalty and respect for that god exists
that we believe certain things and we
don't believe
other things we ought to teach them
those
children will be taught values it is not
possible to have education without
values
i know there's this kind of liberal
dream among
left-wing liberals but even some
right-wing liberals you know people who
say
i just i want to get the indoctrination
out of the classroom i just want them to
learn
their arithmetic and you know the three
r's or no
it doesn't work that way education is
about the whole person it's about
developing virtues suppressing vices
understanding how to view the world and
the left is very successful at this and
the right is very unsuccessful
at this because this is actually the
topic of my book my upcoming book that
amazon is almost certainly going to
cancel
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
we conservatives like to believe that we
understand education
so much better than the left does we
understand free speech so much better
than the left us
i don't think we do i think that the
left and i think
the intellectual leftists who developed
the system that we now call woke-ism
or political correctness or or whatever
word you want to use for it i think they
understood those things
much better than conservatives do and
it's why they were able to transform it
and only by understanding what they
really think
or we're going to be able to change
course because our current strategy on
this
is failing if you enjoyed that video be
sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
[Music]